Vì ra đang chín khác một chiến sự chuyện quay quay quý mồ lớn nhằm và các phần tự tình y là giãn diệp
quý seren hoạt động đổi đẹp. Theo hàng Phas News, bày trong đối tượng bị bắt giữ chỉ trong phòng
mười hai ngày gần nhất, đưa chơi là có liên hệ với mô sát, khu quan tình bảo nước ngoài
quý seren. Giới trước anh đi, ra em cho biết những người này phần lớn thủ mặt lưu giãn diệp tháng báo,
bị phát hiện qua hoạt động phản giãn và tổ giá của người dân.
Tại hay ra em cũng cứu gọi toàn dân cạnh giá khảo độ để nghị trình báo các giống hiệu bất thường như phương tiện gì chuyện trái sở,
người điao kính giám ban đêm hai mang và dụng khảy, chính quyền đi ra em cho rằng các đảng vụ mô sát đối vũ trở bởi mạng lối nổi giãn
và đã chín khai hàng nghiênh thì bị bay không người lấy, để hỗ trợ không quân yên xoran trong các cuộc không kích.
Trong khốn của chính dịch, ý ra em còn tiến hành các ít tên ấy trên tòn quốc, để chạp đường liên là cuộc các nhóm tình báo.
Bởi vì yên xoran nước này chưa có phản huổi chính thức. Chúng khi đoàn các chuyên gia của tế nhận định chính xí của ý ra em cho thấy mức độ lâu ngại thực sự,
trước sự sân nhập của mô sát, tuy nhiên một số ý kiến hoàn yý với có số bẩy chăm, trước rằng đây có thể là anh đậu mắt giảm hơn bỏ sốt,
giữa lúc hệ thống anh đến yên ra em giới và trận thái căn thẳng tượng độ. Trong bối cảnh các thẳng trụ đồng chưa hạnh nghiệp,
phản nướng mạng tay từ ý ra em cho thấy cuộc chiến tình báo dưới hai của gia khó thể còn kéo dài và phức tạm hơn.